so what you ran into somebody recently
because I remember sitting next to you
the voice and you're like okay
[Music]
listen ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
first of all this is what I really want
to ask keep this photo up who is this
guy who who is this guy but he seems
angry at you specifically let me tell
the story so uh so you know I'm in the
visual art space right now so I go to a
lot of like Arts fairs like stuffy
events and stuff and so freeze Los
Angeles is happening and I went to like
the the launch party for it and I see
Owen Wilson who I'm a huge fan of like
all the different genre
Owen Wilson fan like films I like I like
drill bit Taylor but also like all the
Wes Anderson films I like wedding
crashes of course I could go on I could
give you a dissertation right now on why
he's so dope wow he's fired not at the
Museum yeah not at the Museum I love
that one yes all right so then so I see
you're hilarious dude so I didn't throw
it in so I see Owen Wilson at this party
I'm like oh my God this is Owen Wilson I
go up to him I'm like hey I wanna I
wanna just give you your flowers and
tell you how dope you are and you know
meet you and he was super nice he was
like I love your work let's take a
picture I'm like let's take a picture
he's like but let's do it like we're
talking to each other like we're in
conversation I'm like bet my homie Reese
is right next to us he just starts
flicking us up and the first flick
um you see Enemy Number One let's do
right here
with this spy jacket on is is eyeballing
me but I don't see him yet go to the
next photo
this guy jumped in line and started
talking to Owen Wilson wait can you see
oh Owen's face right now he's not into
but here's the crazy thing he made it
seem you know sometimes you can make it
seem like you know somebody like oh I
haven't seen you in so long or they make
a joke and that's what he did he just
stepped on the conversation he goes oh
yeah and all this is like oh you have a
show I guess look at this he's like I
guess go to the next photo
that's me
that's me I turned because I'm starting
to realize
this guy doesn't know Owen Wilson
so I tell Owen Wilson
nobody treats you like this and I got
that guy up out of there go to the next
slide
yeah that's me telling him he's got to
go and that lady behind him is saying
yeah it's time to go buddy because we
were on Wilson security oh man he maybe
had too much to drink got super
confident I'm not giving him any excuses
he's probably completely sober that's
just his personality okay and then go to
the next photo I think we have a happy
ending happy ending it's me conversion
[Applause]
[Music]
God I just love I was like who's the
creeper I was like who's in the photo
with you boo you dude I know I love you
so much
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I'm going